all right as I said before I'm pretty
much done with theatrically released
video game movies the best or fun most
of the time to [ __ ] a Netflix series
that's new territory let's bring that on
[Music]
Castlevania Season one I just say
Castlevania season 1 I created so
Castlevania is on Netflix it's only four
episodes long for 25-minute episodes
long which immediately bummed me out
because that's all season 1 was on I was
like alright I'm going to watch season 1
about what 10 to 13 episodes 1 hour long
each let's do it then it's called the
running time of the episodes like August
the 25 minutes each 10 episodes
still feeling good but in episode 4 it's
like in this season 1 finale but
basically the premise is exactly what I
heard the premise was going to be pretty
much a Netflix series of Castlevania
based on Castlevania 3 Dracula's curse
you see Castlevania 3 Dracula's curse
and here you see some war from Symphony
of the Night and what they had to do in
here is a pretty difficult task and that
is to take an 8-bit video game and
create a script around it and hopefully
execute it well in directing a
Castlevania in Castlevania 3 the
Castlevania games have had this story
there but not a script in terms of
dialogue of the characters nuance I
don't know Trevor Belmonts personality
from playing Castlevania 3 Dracula's
curse what got him on this road what was
his attitude like in the beginning if
you're going off Castlevania 3 it's like
if it's a Castlevania game with some
characters and you have to write the
story around it creating a story
creating lore for an 8-bit Nintendo game
we've seen it happen before
doesn't always work they had some
freedom to translate in the best way
they saw that can help in a situation
like this it can be a hindrance you
don't want to take too many liberties
because then you just did what video
game movies do so the fact they pulled
it off here right of applause but
episode 1 of this show grabbed me I
loved as far as first episodes go this
is perfect it's what you had to do it is
really Dracula centric it concentrates
on Dracula Dracula meets this woman who
would become his wife and a bunch of
religious zealots burn her at the stake
he's like alright humanity will screw
you and one year later he unleashes all
the forces of Hell on mankind town by
town which is so great it's so much
Dracula storyline and lore that I wanted
I know they've done that in Castlevania
games before like lords of Shadow is
very hey here's the origin of Dracula
most of the time in Castlevania games
including Castlevania three you know
Dracula is the bad guy you've run into
him at the end and then you kill him but
episode 1 of this was like why is
Dracula bad and the greatest thing is
you really empathize with this guy I
mean as Dracula becomes Dracula after
the first episode really most of the bad
guys you see are the religious zealot
seems look at those people you look at
Dracula you're like yeah I'd probably
kill them too but dragon it does taking
a few steps further it says hey why not
humanity but it's always great when
something can make you empathize with
the villain like I get it man that was
shitty but I did want to see more of
Dracula and his wife I wanted to see the
two of them really bond I wanted to see
that love that he would then lose but
it's basically they meet and then the
next scenes I got twenty years later so
you don't really get that in here
doesn't mean you can't see it in
flashbacks I got season - coming back
goes well we'll have season three so
they can fill in the gaps of Dracula's
love and what he actually lost give it
to you in portions you know that could
be good and I like Trevor Belmont in
here the Belmonts usually being the main
character you play as in a Castlevania
game a protagonist to Dracula's
antagonist but it was kind of a snarky
drunk washout the Belmont family is a
big name everyone knows all their demon
hunters their vampire hunters but at a
point for reasons unknown society just
kind of said yeah we don't need your
help anymore get lost so now he's in a
bar he's a drunk and really the main
thing that happens in season one is
Belmont comes across this town that's
being ravaged and terrorized by
Dracula's demon and he helps the super
secret organization of helpful monks
called speakers because they speak their
history they don't write it down which
is the worst way to pass on history ever
ever play that game or you line up 20
people and tell one a story and that
person tells the next person the same
story and that person told the next one
the same story and by the end of the
twenty people it's a completely
different story yeah they never played
that because they think it's a good idea
to be like let's not write anything down
let's just talk the point is he helps
them out in the end it sets up precision
- in that the show is great setup for
the Castlevania series that is to come
I'm sure I won't lie four episodes the
kind of a bummer you're like I could go
for more like I said on Twitter I feel
like the nicest of the entertainment
critique someone could ever give is I
wish it were longer I didn't enter a
bunch of dick jokes on my Twitter you
really do feel like Netflix was testing
the water with this and I totally get
why like all you want to do an animated
Castlevania sure let's do four episodes
for half hour long episode this is wise
I totally get it but now that the show
is getting praise and people seem to
enjoy it season two was supposed to be
longer great and before parents go yeah
I'm totally going to sit little Timmy
down he would like this
no it's animated man but this is a
mature a story mature story mature
animation
and after the whole Dracula thing goes
down you're like oh that's violent these
guys are talking to bar like oh it all
sick [ __ ] it you're like oh oh oh guys
I'll bring the adult really though you
look at the potential of what this could
be it really could be the animated Game
of Thrones
Castlevania story you've probably wanted
since Game of Thrones happen I was like
it's not going to be a live-action but
I'll take animators the animation is
actually really good it's crisp it's
clean and in terms of directing to use
the animation to show imagery that
totally parallels what the mood is
supposed to be what's being said is one
scene where this priest is talking all
you see is his fist while he's talking
he's talking about these people are my
it was completely effective I could have
gone for more Dracula's oh not just in
the beginning I like it when a show
shows both sides of the story and
granted you've got Dracula slide in the
first episode but while the shit's going
down is he still racked with grief does
he have regret like when you see an
infant baby in the mouth of a demon will
the demons running off with it to eat it
what you do see is Dracula is he
mournful as he's sorry does he act tough
but then go to the picture of his wife
and just kind of cry and then make a
fist and turn go back to killing people
I don't know if there is a story to tell
from Dracula's side maybe we'll get that
in season two maybe they tried it and
season one they were like not trust us
it didn't really flow so we took it out
I don't know this show gets you so
interested in Dracula in Episode one
that's not really have any of him
throughout the rest of it you kind of
felt bummed out your investors now and
the show was a lot more humor than I
thought to lose some of the dark humor a
belmonts kind of a funny snaky ass guy
it's kind of that Han Solo vibe in that
he just finds a lot of his [ __ ]
ridiculous he's like Laver you're just
gonna die by the way I like me some
bloody dark guys in the end Castlevania
season one was I thought it was great
for what it is if it was theatrically
released and this is all you got you'd
be like no it doesn't feel like a
complete movie but that is the
advantageous thing about using the
Netflix or streaming platform hey here's
a little taste there's season one do you
like it yeah can you get another one of
these next year sure can so this was a
great way to go about it it was very
smart as they check it out it's worth
watching it's worth supporting I don't
want this thing to get Firefly it
although we do have season two coming
that's just season two I want to see a
lot more man this could be quite a
medieval animated epic but alright guys
so Castlevania season one have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more
[Music]